Jacques Chirac vous fait demander de le
rejoindre vous prenez le petit escalier
Napoléon 3 en colimaçon et quand vous
arriz Chirac vous dit ça y est je crois
que je suis
élu alors bernadetteirac bonsoir est-ce
que je peux vous appeler Bernadette ou
bien vous préférez Madame Chirac ou
Bernie Bernadette
[Musique]
Bernadette
donc
Bernadette Bernadette vous êtes ici ce
soir pour parler sex drog et rock and
roll ah bah ouais jeis ah bah si
c'estissant vous êtes pas chez drer
quand même c'est vrai vousz pas me faire
les yeux noirs que vous faites à votre
mari quand il parle à une autre femme
Bernadette je fais pas les yeux
[Musique]
noirs Bernadette rebonsoir vous avez
déclaré me contenter d'être l'épouse du
premier retraité de France non merci
tant que je peux être utile je continue
il y a tant à faire pour les enfants
hospitalisés les adolescents les
handicapés les personnes âgées et bien c
anné encore vous continuer l'ex première
dame de France est toujours madame pièce
jaune l'opération a commencé le 5
janvier elle se poursuit jusqu'au 12
février au côté de Lori et d'un nouveau
parrain Christian carambeti caramb c'est
un garçon absolument charmant qui est
très très gentil avec les enfants qui
sait leur parler qui est joyeux euh qui
communique bien aussi avec les équipes
soignantes avec les parents et il a
accepté tout de suite d'embla de donner
du temps pour les petits enfants malades
hospitalisé comment on fait pour donner
donc il a les fameuses tirlir alors il y
a les tirlir que nous avons relooké
l'année
dernière avec un personnage pile et un
personnage face n'est plus la petite
maison ouais on les retire ces tirlir
dans les 17000 bureau de poste de France
qui est notre premier partenaire et
quand l'opération se termine le 12
février on les ramène plein si possible
au bureau de poste et puis internet
c'est Price Minister et les clients
quand ils achètent sur Price Minister
ils mettent dans leur panier comme on
dit ce qu'ils achètent et à la fin ils
ajoutent des i pièces jaunes c'est la
naissance des i pièces jaunes alors l'an
dernier vous avez récolté 3,5 million
d'euros c'est pas mal hein oui enfin
nous sommes en un peu en perte de
vitesse ouis mais de toute façon c'est
les Français sont très généreux et je
trouve que 3 million et demi d'euros
déjà quand on a beaucoup de difficultés
dans beaucoup de familles du chômage il
faut remercier tous ces donateurs qui
sont solidaires de notre de nos pièces
jaunes alors quand on voit ce que vous
faites ça ne peut qu'inciter à donner en
2010 la Fondation a financé 399 projets
a commencé par plusieurs maisons des
parents pour permettre aux parents
d'être présents au côté des des enfants
hospitalisés et depuis 1990 il y a eu
6700 projets financés dans 433 villes 41
maisons des parents 838 chambres mère-
enfant on verra ça dans la 3è partie de
l'émission 42 maisons des adolescents et
1059 pompes anti-douleur et last but not
least la Cour des comptes a qualifié
d'exemplaire l'utilisation des dons
collectés c'est pas le cas de tout le
monde
[Musique]
bravo voilà
bravo alors Bernadette votre nom de
jeune fille c'est Bernadette chaudron de
courcell vieille lignée française
anoblie par Napoléon II votre oncle
joffroid était au côté du général de
Gaulle quand il est parti à Londres le
17 juin 1940 c'était son aide de camp B
voilà votre père Jean-Louis lui
dirigeait des manufactures les émau de
Brillard et les faillances de Gen il
était fait prisonnier à la guerre en en
40 et il a passé 4 ans en captivité
ensuite alors famille trècato hein éti
dans une école qui s'appelait Sainte
Marie des fleurs et des fruits c'est
joli ça non c'était pendant la guerre où
j'avais quand même 12 km à faire à
bicyclette tous les jours j'étais
demipensionnaire et B c'était le nom de
cette école elle s'appelle toujours
comme ça alors vous avez toujours un
Chapel sur vous dont un qui vous a été
donné par jean-pa I ça me rassure ouais
j'essaie de prier le plus possible dans
la journée pas assez sûrement là vous
l'avez le chapelet non je l'ai pas sur
ça ve dire vous êtes pas inquiète alors
j'espère alors votre mère vous avez Duqu
àelle la dur elle avait une phrase
terrible c'est on ne se couche que pour
mourir j'ai été élevé sévèrement c'est
vrai mais j'en dis merci à mes parents
parce que ça aide beaucoup après surtout
quand on est un épouse Jacques chir
qu'il faut être bien dressé
Ahou ah ouais c'est un sacré animal
alors votre père suit vos étude vous
pousse vers science poau où vous entrez
en 1950 et c'est là que vous rencontrez
Jacques Chirac alors la première fois
que vous le voyez vous dites c'est quoi
C escogriff qui remue nerveusement la
jambe il l'a fait longtemps d'ailleurs
maintenant il le fait plus du tout ça
doit être un signe de
l'âge il avait déjà beaucoup de culot
ouais et alors après ça bon ben j'ai
fait partie de son groupe de travail pu
vous savez
il y avait quand même le
choix sa mère se prend d'affection pour
vous et au moment où il tombe amoureux
d'une américaine à la nouvelle orléance
je crois que c'est en 51 elle vous
supplie de le ramener à la maison quand
même parce qu'elle voulait pas avoir une
belle fille américaine elle avait très
peur de ça voilà alors chez vous c'est
pas pareil hein euh Zac shirac est quand
même le Petitfils d'un instituteur
francmaçon il est pas religieux il a pas
fait sa confirmation il a pas d'argent
il était baptisé quand même mais bon
ouis c'est que mes grands-parents
m'avaient demandé est-ce au moins un
être baptisé baptisé
ou mais vous êtes accro quand même hein
vous vous passez là-dessus quoi comme
vous dites voilà mais était magnifique
hein éit beau garçon ah ça il était très
beau garçon il avait énormément de
succès auprès des jeunes filles et
c'était de véritables batailles rangé
autour de lui mais il le savait aussi
hein c'était un peu
énervant alors en 53 vous fiancez et en
54 Jacques Chirac prépare Lena et vous
vous renoncez à votre carrière
universitaire et vous prenez même des
cours de dactilo pour taper ces dossiers
c'est quelle abnégation quand même nonou
non c'était parce que je voulais qu'il
réussisse ah ou ou bah oui il a réussi
Lena du premier coup il a réussi le
concours d'entrée sans faire d'année
préparatoire ce qui est assez rare ce
qui fait que dans votre famille on se
dit finalement il est pas grand-mère m'a
dit après m'avoir dit tu nous ramènes un
gamin ouais elle m'a dit mais alors
c'est un génie ah ben voilà ça y est
alors c'était pas tout à fait un gamin
mais pas non plus un
génie alors jeune marié il vous appelait
tout le temps chez vous il éta exaspéré
quand il vous trouvait pas il voulait
absolument que vous soyez là disponible
quoi ah oui c'est ça oui ouis mais oui
tu es fils unique qu'est-ce que vous
voulez alors tout a toujours tourné
autour de lui et une fois marié il
voulait que ça continue mais aujourd'hui
c'est pareil hein c'est pareil
aujourd'hui il vous appelle tout le
temps non mais c'est vrai ça le rassure
probablement alors à l'époque vous avez
épousé jacquesac vous ne vous doutiez
pas du du destin qui qui l'attendait et
votre beau-père disait mon fils sera
gouverneur de la Banque de France
j'aurais bien aimé d'ailleurs oui vous
auriez été plus tranquille peut-être
ou et alors des années plus tard le 7
mai 1995 à 19h30 vous êtes à l'hôtel de
ville de Paris Jacques Chirac vous fait
demander de le rejoindre vous prenez le
petit escalier Napoléon 3 en colimçon et
quand vous arrivez Chirac vous dit ça y
est je crois que je suis
élu et là vous ressentez un changement
pratiquement physique chez lui c'est
vrai qu'à ce moment-là il y a cette
émotion énorme et il m'a semblé que mon
mari avait changé de posture ouais et
vous vous avez changé à partir de ce
moment-là sûrement moins que lui ouais
vous AES dit j'ai fait le bon choix
quand même euh enfin j'aurais pu en
faire un autre
oui alors 7 ans plus tard en 2002 vous
êtes la seule à prévoir que Jean-Marie
Le Pen sera au deuxème tour oui parce
que ce que je sais faire dans les
campagnes électoral c'est aller dans les
rues dans les villes saluer les
commerçants quelquefois il y a des gens
qui vous invite à monter chez eux ça
permet de faire une sorte de sondage à
la fin et de se dire B il y a pas de
doute il y a tellement de gens qui
disent Madame Chirac je voterai pour Le
Pen que vous finissez par avoir une
angoisse et je disais à mon mari à
l'Élysée vous savez Le Pen monte Le Pen
monte je ne vous dis pas ce qu'il me
répondait parce que c'est assez grossier
pour
moi sauf que vous aviez raison quoi oui
il a reconnu que j'avais été la seule à
le dire alors vous qui savez tout est-ce
que Sarkozi va être élu en 2012
Bernadette d'abord je le pense et
ensuite je le
souhaite alors aujourd'hui vous avez
tourné la page de votre vie de première
dame de France quand on vous demande si
vous la regrettez vous avez une réponse
formidable vous dites simplement it's
different c'est différent il y a un côté
très chic comme ça never explain never
complain oui c'est différent puis enfin
on n'est pas propriétaire
d'une d'une fonction officielle que les
Français vous ont confié
démocratiquement par leur vote on sait
très bien qu'un jour bon mon mari a
maintenant 78 ans hélas puis il a fait
deux mandats quand même donc il a fait
de mandats donc de toute façon il avait
décidé de s'arrêter et je pense qu'il
faut se reconstruire si on le peut une
fois qu'on a quitté le ses
responsabilités ce qui est différent
vous c'est que maintenant vous vous
éclatez hein vous ah non mais c'est vrai
on vous a même vu dans des boîtes de
nuit à saint-tropé cet été
Bern parce que le le fils estîné de
Bernard et Hélène Arnaud est un
excellent DJ j'avais d'ailleurs beaucoup
d'autres amis c'était très gay ce ce qui
est très drôle c'est quand votre mari
vous demande si sil peut venir vous
dites NON NON Jacques vous n'êtes pas
invité oui bah oui parce que ça va pas
avec sa mentalité oui ça lui plairait
pas c'est pas son truc les C du roi
tellement drôle vous savez alors lui ce
qu'il dit mais c'est pourtant grâce à
moi que vous êtes invité Bernadette
c'est toujours grâce à lui si je suis
assise là en face lui gr d'accord c'est
pas grâce aux pièces jaunes non et il
dit toujours ne l'oubliez pas vous avez
une chance formidable de m'avoir épousé
oui ça ça plusieurs fois par jour ah oui
ah oui oui ça plusieurs fois par jour
mais quand vous sortez seul c'est un peu
une vengeance parort à l'époque où lui
sortait tout seul non ben il il n'est
jamais beaucoup sorti vous savez mon fr
c'est pas du tout un mondain ouais c'est
pas quelqu'un qui dînit en ville il a eu
tort d'ailleurs ouais il se serait mis
dans la poche un peu l'intelligigencia
et tout ça c'est pas tellement quelqu'un
qui allait qui qui allait au théâtre n
la musique n'en parlons pas il n'aime
pas du tout la musique il ne s'en cache
pas d'ailleursou mais oui c'est c'est un
peu dommage alors vous allez bientôt
fêter vos 55 ans de a effant c'est
terrible c'est les noces d'uranium enri
ça non c'est long hein j'espère qu'il me
fera un cadeau hein c'est
long alors vous lui avez souvent dit le
jour où Napoléon a abandonné Joséphine
il a tout perdu ce qui est vrai
d'ailleurs vous savez bien il les
papillons qui tournent autour de la
lampe ouais ouais ouais la lampe qui
donne de la lumière ouais j'avais assez
peur de ça vous croyez qu'il nous
regarde là ah ça c'est certain il
s'assia en général le plus près possible
de l'écran ouais vous voulez lui dire un
mot là ben bonsoir merci de m'avoir
permis de
venirmission et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater debe abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce
bleu